[Music]
today we have to cancel a woman named
whitney levitt who has amassed a
following of uh half a million fans on
tick tock mostly from what i can tell by
lip syncing and dancing while pregnant
now tick tock has proven that there's an
enormous market out there for 12-second
videos of people lip-syncing and dancing
but in order to really make it big on
the platform you need to discover your
own niche within that category your own
twist
so some people lip-sync and dance while
only partially clothed
some people lip-sync a dance dance while
not clothed at all
others lip-sync and dance while wearing
funny outfits there are people
lip-syncing and dancing while
cross-dressing you know
i saw one woman who was lip-syncing and
dancing while being very old so that was
her own special variation on the theme
and all these people have like lots and
lots of followers on tick tock but
whitney had the pregnant lip sync dance
genre cornered until her tic-tock career
was derailed because she had her baby
and so she was no longer pregnant
and searching for some new creative
inspiration she found her opportunity
when her newborn child came down with uh
the respiratory virus rsv
now three of my kids had rsv as babies
all of them had to go to the hospital
for it
and i can tell you it's an extremely
scary experience because while the virus
manifests as a cold in adults much like
omnicorn it can kill a very young child
unlike omnicorn
it would be an understatement to say
that while at the hospital with my
severely sick children i was not in a
dancing mood now to be to be fair i'm
never in a dancing mood but if i were to
ever experience the strange and
arbitrary urge to move my body to the
rhythm of music it would not be at the
hospital with a sick child
now whitney on the other hand takes a
different approach to parenting and so
she recorded and posted this video at
the hospital while standing next to her
newborn child who was struggling to
breathe let's watch
[Music]
now for those listening only to the
audio let me paint the mental picture
for you um whitney wearing a bright pink
nirvana sweater despite i'm sure not
being able to name more than two nirvana
songs at most
that's beside the point uh whitney is
standing in a hospital room next to her
newborn child
performing a choreographed dance routine
while the captions on the screen inform
us that he has rsv has low oxygen levels
and cannot breathe well on his own
now we should note that it's not even a
sad song and dance either this isn't
like an interpretive performance where
she's communicating her sadness and
anxiety through dance
that would also be completely insane but
this somehow manages to be even crazier
because the song and dance are upbeat
meanwhile her son is lying helplessly in
the bassinet
looking at the camera with a distinct
get away from me woman
expression on his face
now
if you really wanted to make excuses for
whitney which i don't
you might argue that all of the dancing
nurses over the last two years have
given people the mistaken impression
that hospital rooms also double as dance
studios
i'm just glad that this trend took hold
after my achilles surgery a few years
ago because if i had the same procedure
today i'd probably wake up from
anesthesia to discover that there's a
viral video on tick-tock of my surgeon
dancing around my unconscious body while
he stitches together my shattered
tendons tendons
so i think i've escaped that sort of
thing um but now my nightmare is that
you know sometime in the future i'll go
in for some routine blood work or
something only to have the doctor and 15
nurses come dancing into the room with a
marching band to inform me that i have
stage four cancer and i'll be dead in
three months that's where this is headed
now all that being said
this is no excuse for whitney who should
have known better all the same and she
now acknowledges that and she issued a
tearful apology a couple of days later
after her video failed to receive the
applause that she was hoping for this is
what she said
i understand people are upset
with the video that i made
i just want to be clear and
communicate that that was me just trying
to be positive
i think it's important to just not just
assume
what someone's going through
anyways i took the video down
because i could see
you know
where somebody could get the wrong idea
but
that honestly was just me just trying to
be positive
in this situation but
i do want to say thank you for people
who
have reached out to me and my family and
i just really appreciate it
yeah well she's the victim here you see
the victim of the content that she
posted on the internet to her massive
crowd of followers she says that she was
just trying to be positive
well there's certainly nothing wrong
with that
people try to stay positive i've been to
plenty of funerals where people are
laughing and joking finding joy even in
grief it's a very common coping
mechanism but the problem here is not
positivity
the problem isn't even necessarily the
dancing now if i walked into a room and
found a mother dancing alone around her
sick child
i would think that it was super weird
and i'd be very uncomfortable having
witnessed it but i'd probably assume
that it was some kind of like religious
ritual or something
the main point is that it would be none
of my business
if i were to just walk into a room and
see that
if that's how you cope in private well
okay that's your affair
but this was not private
she made the decision to record edit
and post this content to the internet
she wasn't merely staying positive she
was using her child's sickness as
content for social media
she didn't stay positive she stayed
posting and that's the issue here
speaking of funerals this reminds me of
the influencer a few weeks ago i think i
mentioned on the show who found herself
in the middle of a similar firestorm
when she posed for seductive photos next
to her father's open casket and posted
them to instagram and she captioned it
butterfly fly away r.i.p poppy you were
my best friend a life well-lived now
once again
there's nothing wrong with that
sentiment the problem is that she felt
the need to post pictures of herself
with her dad's corpse on social media
that's not coping that's content
what should have been a very personal
and private moment becomes an
opportunity to bring attention to
yourself
now she justified herself the one with
the corpse um after the fact by saying
everybody handles their loss of a loved
one in their own way some some are more
traditional while others might come
across as taboo
for me i treated the celebration as if
my father was right next to me posing
for the camera as he had done on many
occasions prior
but again
she's free to grieve in her own way to
celebrate her father's life in her own
way to go through this privately in
whatever way she sees fit it's none of
our business
unless you make it our business
which in this case she did
and when that happens we are free to ask
why i mean what motivates people to
bring these sacred and intimate moments
into the public sphere
exploiting their own trauma for content
cashing in their grief and misery for
likes and shares why do people do it
i think there are a few factors but one
that we could consider is that um
you know this new crop of social media
influencers
grew up with the internet on it in it
they've never had a private life
they've been on stage effectively almost
since birth living in front of an
audience
now everybody knows that child actors
usually grow up to become deeply
disturbed and troubled adults why is
that well because they never experienced
normal human existence
they were famous before they could
understand what fame meant and certainly
before they could really choose it for
themselves
they've been performing for so long they
never had a chance to develop a real
personality
a real interior life
so they grow into these stunted hollow
people
and they try to fill that gap in that
hollowness in with drugs and everything
else
well the problem is that now all kids
have child actor syndrome
the only difference is that most of them
don't have millions of dollars to show
for it but they get on the internet and
social media early in life
and they begin cultivating their own
little audience
and they become small scale public
figures performing for the crowd
trying constantly to appease and grow
their fan base
though they can't explain what they gain
from it
and this is true of adults too everybody
is a public figure now
on one scale or another everyone is
famous in their own way
only most people get the worst parts of
fame
the lack of privacy the narcissism
the constant crushing fear that you'll
become
irrelevant but none of the perks money
admiration success
and this is how we end up with people
who put everything on the internet who
publish publicize every detail of
themselves
who use every experience and every
thought and every misfortune and trauma
as content
mere fuel to shove into the fire
that's how whitney levitt happens
though this is not an excuse
we still must hold individuals
accountable for their own behavior which
is why today she is
still at the end canceled well i hope
you enjoyed that clip from the matt wall
show if you did go ahead and hit that
subscribe button right down there so you
can stay up to date on all of our future
content